I'm pleased to know that our colleagues
at MIT are reaching out to people all
over the world to engage them in this
important discussion about the future of
work we are launching our own future of
work initiative here at the ILO and this
course will fit very well with our
initiative look I think that our future
of work initiative responds to two
essential things once got to do with
need once got to do with opportunity the
need comes from the fact and we're all
conscious of this in our everyday lives
that there is massive change taking
place in the world of work
transformative change at a pace and at a
depth that we don't really have
experience of in the past so we think
that we need to study these big changes
to understand them better as a way of
working out what we should do about them
in order to make sure that the world of
work responds to the Aiello's ideas of
social justice fairness at work and then
there is the opportunity and the
opportunity comes from the fact that in
in three years time in 2019 the ILO will
celebrate its hundredth birthday its
centenary so what better opportunity
they don't come round that frequently
what better opportunity than that to
have this in-depth reflection about the
direction that the world of work is
taking and what we can do to shape it to
move it towards these ideals of social
justice we are proposing to our member
states that they structure their
national dialogues around for
conversations and very quickly one is to
do with work and society sounds a bit
philosophical but I think there are some
really deep questions out there about
what work means to each and every one of
us in terms of not only of earning our
living but also of self realization of
our you know what our life's mean and
and how we want to proceed with them
secondly and it's the most frequently
asked question that I at least get about
the future is decent work of tomorrow
the decent jobs of tomorrow where are
those jobs coming from we're having to
create 40 million jobs every year just
to absorb the new people coming on to
the labor markets and frankly we're not
able to do it at the
so we have to be able to discuss the
nature and the origin of work in the
future the third item is about the
organization the organization of work
and production you know we're seeing the
digital economy take off we're seeing
the way that the Internet is mediating
work in entirely new ways maybe the
enterprise is going to look very
different in the future from what it
looks like today we're seeing the
fragmentation and globalization of
production systems in global supply
chains we need to understand what the
full implications are of this new
organization and global division of
labor and the fourth point and this is
the culminating point of the of the
whole thing we have to say well what are
the consequences of these changes for
the Aiello's mandate for social justice
how can we shape manage all of these
changes so that we keep the world moving
in this direction of social justice so
let me end by encouraging everyone to
join us in using the ideas and the
information presented in this course to
improve the future of work for people
all around the world